siamo arrivati all'ultimo episodio di
mira honey che bello che bello poterlo
dire tutto questo salvo è ancora lì
vabbè volevo dirvi ragazzi questo è
l'ultimo episodio godetevelo e buona
visione
non siete un cazzo ecco qua ma qualcuno
zacco la battaglia di t ma non ci guardi
guardati guardar di madonna il
calcinculo che ti dopo un'ora e mezza
per fare il corso è questa quale arriva
e si mette davanti a [ __ ]
oh mio dio o scienza è andata e si non
sono anche come fatto a sopravvivere col
culo che hai
abbiamo sbloccato la porta con la chiave
delle scale ben [ __ ] madri fermi sempre
venirgli infatti così ma non puoi fare
le cose con calma qual è il problema
madonna volo [ __ ] aiuta
su su su su verace sopra non a parole
no non ho parole tanto che tutto ma poi
quella non si doveva aprire quanto
minchia vi sembra che ansia lo spaccato
la porta che minchia ragazza gli
articoli ha messo una vita
puzzle in chi tanto per cambiare una
triumph ha già non capisco mi si aprono
le porte normale la madonna permesso
devo entrare dentro ma guarda io
eviterei è chiusa ma dai
ebbene lei facciamo entrare il lupin
game e solo dopo aver visitato stanza
un'acqua che a quanto vedo e molto
velenosa radioattiva ma che ne so via
takeshi ho visto takeshi fermi tutti no
è no e basta
dall 80 paese dove cazzo andato quello
aiuto non ci credo mai da evitare che la
madre ti prego fa che sia proferì si
avrà quando la l'ammontare di culo che
sto avendo in questo gioco è incredibile
ma che culo l'unica porta che poteva
aprire a questa è chiusa ma non c'è
neanche buco per la chiave come posso
aprirla credo di aver capito che parli
delle leve quindi quelle le vedi primo
introdotto la parola leve e poi un'altra
parola sembrava verso credo che sia
change the level vers quindi io devo
cambiare sicuramente il cose delle leve
oa destra per forza ho capito solo la
parola leve
[Musica]
guai
c'era qualcosa di bilanciato sopra la
porta è caduta quando siamo entrati da
culo tu non sei un mostro potevi farci
del male davvero
beh come faceva a sapere che stavate
arrivando mi fa piacere vederli
state mangiando sushi tutti insieme
quindi come sta andando la merda insomma
cioè noi come stare in discoteca perché
questo è stato takeshi che bello sapere
che va tutto bene grazie takuro mi hai
salvato dove sono gli altri non ho
trovato nessuno spero che mendy e ryan
stiamo bene
mancano solo loro due la fine è il tipo
l'ha uccisa lei è morta quindi è morta
mica è andata e non c'è niente possiamo
fare ma no anzi messa piante ma è vero
che un bambino lui manovra mancato solo
i [ __ ] di questi come dovrebbe
andare a prenderlo morirà da fuori
vado io posso fare da chi ce la posso
fare ma non farò era 22 la risposta ma
quindi non c'entrava la sedia con
l'apertura della porta stoccolma
affanculo
e allora now i'm not going dark room
like that but no swan lurking around
sono sti cosi scusami si sposta luce
dentro ma tua sorella quelli dove
illuminare qualcosa
questa deve illuminare di preciso
di soli su quattro no l'altra macchia
nera 2 ha fatto luce tutta la stanza in
questo dovesse illuminare sono quella
roba lì questa roba parte che ci viene
oggi ve lo giuro che appena finisco di
giocare sta roba da accendere un cero in
chiesa e un prisma che riflette a voce
tutta la star ma figurati se ne andrà
accorgevo prima destra ma come ha fatto
a tua sorella morta vai vai mai più
mezzi e mezzo ditemi voi se devo essere
costretto a farsi le cose ci ha regalato
da chi esci da takeshi dietro pochi a
[ __ ] denaro da lui stesso nei palloni
aree di rigore
sono andato all'altro me no è chiusa
come chiusa perché è chiusa adesso al
registro insomma da veramente ma almeno
intorno se è tornato qua dentro
non ho trovato da che era lì dietro
tacche porca vacca infame
chiusa ma non è più chiusa ma la prima
era chiusa ma non è chiusa ma decidetevi
o
ma dio ti benedica aiuto ma io c'è un
coso grock ciccione bello grosso è tanto
riguarda falsa ragazze giusti che
l'addio di dio dio diceva già aperto la
morte che non riesco a fare le cose
legate cazzo di roba peruta cos'è sta
roba del mostro più brutto che abbia mai
visto via via via veloce non posso
bloccarlo in qualche rigore aiuto
aiutatemi che siete miei amici poi aia
mi scarico nel cesso mina plus aiuto
vado anche per il modico e pulendo zio
ci manca solo quello guarda aiuto aiuto
non posso più uscire merda
c'è tra un modo per marco nostra
deficiente madonna fa mi salverà partita
per l'amore di dio e quindi a posto
posso andare in quanto all'addio grazie
no
no non torno in bangadi sparma affanculo
sono processo rumore non devi torna che
bello cerchiamo gioco delle sedie
giramento da jesse o mi offrirono che
cazzo è successo perché ryan non sei mai
venuto cercava crover che si che essi
takuro gli altri li stanno cercando
ma credo che si voglia che ti porto
fuori di qui ok ok perfetto
vorrei andare a casa ball subito zio
parlarne anch'io non ora
exit internet non ci dovrei andare però
ci vado solo per tossici d'armi in ferie
ma che sono masochista perché sci che
non è la porta di takeshi questa che
cos'è sta roba
poi gesù fermi tutti è un piedistallo
[Musica]
kat
ho messo solo ho messo una bambola che
avevo su un piedistallo beh non solo una
le foto vabbè non ho capito cosa ci
posso fare ancora guarito pro piazzato
una bambola
nella lista ha la voce visto st parte
non me lo sono sognato io quello cioè
prima ora ho rimesso il bicchiere
d'acqua nel frigo ho rimesso il bie che
io ho ottenuto un bicchiere d'acqua nel
frigo che non serviva un cazzo per ora
c'è ma veramente poca tua sorella ogni
volta e ogni volta mi fa cagare addosso
messo non ci fosse un domani no ho mica
muoiono alla porta dice non lo vogliamo
andarcene non possiamo passare di qua la
cosa si fa seguendo altre già note ma
gambe ma se ti sa se allora sei tardo ma
verame cielo c'è un mostro dietro non
possiamo andare di padre non venga meno
scappare ma senza e satana che c'era
dietro le spalle sarai [ __ ] no ma se
c'è battista stuprando l'anno cosa vuoi
ma cosa gli altri mazziato faber ma come
fa spiega avevo farcire il letto mi ha
[ __ ] trovando davanti giova tale che
siamo usciti dall uscita posteriore
non ho avuto tempo per aspettare gli
altri
appena siamo usciti abbiamo corso più
forti abbiamo corso il più veloce che
abbiamo potuto siamo rimasti in quel
posto orribile per un'ora 57 minuti e 13
secondi e sembrava essere stato dieci
volte più lunghe se il tempo che ci ho
messo io per finire
il gioco va beh e gli altri non si sono
mai fatti più vedere o continuate a
pregare per un po di giorni e poi una
settimana e poi un mese che loro
potessero tornare dei mari
ryan questa questa dal bedendi a me non
è finito e hiroshi non c'è niente per
testimoniare che loro siano esistiti ma
come si che c'è io posso sempre
ricordare che essi sono sicuro che tutti
gli altri lo faranno le varie band come
bed and finito così ciao
ma cosa che cosa si sono fumati il
creatore di questo giocosa vuol dire che
ebbe dandy va bene questo è il big
inning famiglie ma perchè non fai anche
i good ending che raccoglie tutte le
barre no sì spero che la serie vi sia
piaciuta a me è piaciuta abbastanza
trame finale io e rata che sono molto
peggio e ovviamente a ogni non si
battevano con lo sapevo per ragazzi che
vi sia piaciuto come servizio che ci
lascia quanto è un mi piace anche al
soggetto ministro tiziana cioè essere
cities pietri e non ci dividiamo
prossimo vinto dai ragazzi
[Musica]